de retour à dole ici pour la suite et
fin de cette émission la voix libre
exceptionnel consacré à la fusion des
régions et au choix de la future
capitale de la nouvelle région bourgogne
franche comté entre dijon et besançon
lilian avec les deux maires des communes
qui sont restés avec nous sur ce plateau
les deux maires au coeur du dossier le
bisontin jean louis fousseret et le
dijonnais à la bio alors on va un petit
peu jeté un petit pavé dans la mare au
niveau des bisontins on le sait on l'a
beaucoup entendu en tout cas nous sur
les réseaux sociaux on a eu beaucoup de
commentaires comme quoi effectivement
dijon c'était évident ça allait être
choisi on allait se faire manger par les
dijonnais je parle du côté franc comtois
je voudrais vous faire écouter cette
interview si vous le voulez bien c'est
celle du président du mouvement franche
comté jean philippe allenbach qui dit
bien son inquiétude de voir par exemple
dijon capitale de la bourgogne franche
comté et côté c'est pas une surprise on
a toujours dit que ce serait dijon
simplement c'est donc acté du fait que
la grande région ne sera jamais que la
grande bourgogne au moins c'est clair et
net
ça montre également que tout ce qu'on a
pu nous raconter jusqu'à présent
sur l'avenir de besançon finalement
n'était que de l'enfumage ce sera dijon
je le répète c'est sûr et certain et
puis surtout ça a pas montré aux francs
comtois
les premières conséquences concrètes de
ce funeste projet parce que là nous
perdons notre capitale régionale mais
n'oublions pas que très vite nous allons
perdre notre drapeau de la franche-comté
n'ayant pas la personnalité juridique
elle l'appelle ya aucune raison qu'un
drapeau franc comtois figurent au
fronton des monuments publics et puis on
perdra ensuite l'assemblée régionale et
puis on perdra le budget c'est à dire
qu'on ne pourra plus dépenser un centime
sans l'accord des bourguignons lesquels
pourront dépenser ce qu'ils veulent sans
notre accord puisqu'ils auront 57
conseillers et on en aura 43
jean louis fousseret ce qu'il faut
craindre que besançon et plus largement
la franche comté soit dévoré par les
voisins dijonnais et bourguignons oui si
j'entends monsieur allenbach où je
connais me solène bac c'est bon on le
connait tous à besançon on sait ce qu'il
représente bon
c'est ryan crainte néanmoins il y à une
crainte au niveau des francs comtois et
profond toi c'est vrai il y à une
crainte sur le fait qu allons-nous
devenir cette crainte elle existe c'est
pour ça qu'il faut y répondre en donnant
des arguments à 10 ans comme nous
l'avons dit tout au long de cette
émission que l'objectif n'est pas que
l'un dévore l'eau que l'objectif n'est
pas que la franche comté se fasse
absorbé par la bourgogne c'est que
ensemble nous puissions construire une
région plus fort en s'appuyant sur les
atouts que nous avons en bourgogne en
france c'est cela que je ne cesserai de
dire et de répéter jusqu aux élections
jusqu'aux élections régionales alors
ensuite on entend dire que quand même
dans les assemblées j'ai signé d'un
certain nombre d'assemblées des conseils
généraux désormais conseils
départementaux
il ya qu un pas que les intérêts de
territoire on peut imaginer quand même
que l'intérêt général des élus delà de
la bourgogne sera qu' on dépense de
l'argent en bourgogne et en riant
franche comté
ça ne peut pas fonctionner autrement sa
part fonctionnement il faut qu'ils sur
certains grands sujets il y aura
forcément un consensus donc là cette
démarche allait très nettement et
à gérer et ses propos ils sont dangereux
parce qu'ils veulent contribuer ils vont
contribuer à faire peur il faut au
contraire rassuré et discuter discuter
entre nous discuter avec le maire de
dole disait il faut qu'on discute avec
les maires des autres envie d
intégration avec les territoires ruraux
il faut discuter et tout n'est pas figé
gravé dans le marbre on a jusqu'à la fin
de l'année ensemble pour modifier un
certain d'une chose et faire en sorte
que cette réforme se soit une réussite
un succès et je crois qu'avec alain ce
que nous voulons c'est faire en sorte
que nous puissions et de gagnant gagnant
gagnant alain millot c'est rare que la
bourgogne se sentent plus grosse que les
autres parce que c'est pas une grosse
région en france mais là dans cette
situation dans cette configuration est
ce que vous prenez garde justement à
l'état d'esprit que peuvent avoir les
francs comtois dans le cadre de la
fusion et puis des bisons pains dans le
cadre des rapports avec dijon est ce que
vous prenez garde a pas pas y aller trop
fort a pas à prendre le risque sinon de
l'humiliation du moins de rapports
difficiles oui j'y prends garde parce
que je rencontre comme je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure de manière assez régulière
jean louis et jean louis ne ne manque
pas de me le dire de me l'expliquer
parce qu'il le vit sur le terrain que un
certain nombre de francs comtois vont
sont quelque peu inquiet par rapport à
ce qui pourrait se passer
je le dis comme ça au passage moi j'ai
je rencontre sans doute pas tout le
monde en bourgogne mais je n'entends pas
ce même ce même discours ce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est si besoin est
moi je veux rassurer les les francs
comtois que j'aime bien j'ai vécu en
franche-comté j ai travaillé j'y ai
milité donc et j'ai encore beaucoup
d'amis même de la famille si besoin est
les bourguignons ne vont pas manger les
francs comtois je m'y engage
une question peut-être tous les deux
vous êtes du même bord socialiste vous
évoquez tout à l'heure effectivement les
élections à la fin de l'année on va
rentrer à lilian me disais tout à
l'heure on est quand même presque déjà
en campagne pour certains on y est déjà
vous avez effectivement on le sent vous
êtes très proche vous avez envie tous
les deux quand deux capitales des clips
mais quid d'une nouvelle donne au niveau
politique
c'est à dire j'ai dit tout bêtement si
jamais par exemple qu on les conseille
le québécois oui je n'allais ce que si
la droite pas ça peut changer la donne
d'abord on voit se bat pour que cela
n'arrive pas déjà ses frères joe et
ensuite si cela venait à arriver vous
savez sur ses pas c'est pas forcément
impossible eh bien je crois que il y
aurait le même bon sens chez nouveaux
élus que sur ces élus d'aujourd'hui
enfin moi je ne le crois je prends le
problème en amont je le prends dès
maintenant est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
puisque le thème de notre émission c'est
la capitale les infrastructures
institutions et ce qu'il peut y avoir
dans cette campagne des régionales qui
commence en réalité une interaction
entre les candidats et cet élément oui
alors ça je crois que vous avez raison
et c'est pour cela que je suis persuadé
qu'il y aura un partage des
responsabilités qui rend un équilibre si
tel n'était pas le cas cette élection ne
serait plus une élection régionale avec
comme enjeu quel sera le programme de
repos nos régions ça deviendrait un
référendum pour ou contre la réforme et
non le vote serait plus à votre gauche
droite mais ça votre franc comtois
contres bourguignons et là il y aurait
effectivement un risque politique c'est
pour ça que je suis persuadé que le
gouvernement qui a dû faire quelques
analyses politiques quand même est bien
conscient de ce risque alain millot
c'est votre position aussi est-ce que ça
peut arriver est ce qu'on peut se
retrouver avec des candidats qui vont
faire campagne pour si nous savons la
majorité nous déplacerons la capitale
oui c'est possible j'ai envie de dire
qu'il faut qu'on s'attende à tous
d'autant plus quand après avoir entendu
un dernier reportage
faut s'attendre à tout effectivement bon
moi personnellement et très sincèrement
je suis pas trop encore dans la campagne
pas du tout je suis encore beaucoup de
travail beaucoup au travail en bourgogne
et plus particulièrement à dijon et dans
le grand dijon mais je suis au travail
aussi depuis un certain temps avec jean
louis fousseret le maire de besançon je
suis prêt comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure de mettre au travail autour de
la table avec d'autres maires d'autres
mères avec qui manifestement je l' ai
entendu cet après midi est tout à fait
possible de travailler d'avancer
ensemble sur ce que pourra et devra
devenir cette future en région jeudi
devra parce que je voulais quand même
l'indiqué ça dans
mon travail de maire et de président du
grand dijon il ne se passe pas une
semaine sans que je rencontre soit un
partenaire soit une structure
qui me fasse remarquer qu' ils n'ont pas
attendu la fuse le projet de fusion de
régions pour pour faire déjà travaillé
ensemble je note savez bien évidemment
dans le domaine de la santé de la
culture mais pas seulement aussi dans
des entreprises privées dans des grands
groupes bancaires
il se passe pas une semaine sans qu'on
le retourne cette remarque là donc c'est
bien la preuve que les bourguignons et
les franc-comtois quelque part on on
véritablement envie de travailler
ensemble de collaborer d'avancer de se
hisser et il nous faut absolument nous
élus les accompagner à l'ami à une
question plus prosaïque mais un an qu'on
n'a pas encore prononcées dans ce débat
depuis bientôt une heure c'est celui de
françois rebsamen dont on connaît
l'attachement bien sûr à la ville dont
il a été le maire pendant longtemps on
sait qu'un certain nombre de francs
comtois 10 ce sera forcément dijon parce
qu'un ministres importants du
gouvernement va pas laisser besançon
devient la capitale régionale est-ce que
vous en parlez avec françois rebsamen
est ce que vous en avez parlé et est ce
que ce scénario il est vrai est ce que
françois rebsamen serait prêt à laisser
besançon devenir la capitale de la
nouvelle région
bon c'est pas
très très sincèrement voilà we say die
très sincèrement et je suis comme
françois rebsamen dans un un élan de
chauvinisme je vous répondrais très
sincèrement il ne faut pas pratiquer la
langue de bois non plus que ça me ferait
plaisir que dijon soit la capitale mais
je ne m'arrête pas là je reprends tout
ce que nous avons dit depuis un certain
temps avec la question c'est de savoir
est-ce que du coup le le poids du
ministre peut faire pencher la balance
en faveur de dijon parce que c'est un
avantage parce que c'est un avantage
mais vous n'êtes pas ministre alors non
je pense même que je ne le serai jamais
je vis très bien sur scène est-ce que du
coup à cause de sa besançon sera pas
capturé je crois que d'abord l'addition
est prise au ministère de l'intérieur
place beauvau et par le premier ministre
et par le président de la république
pour que françois rebsamen le souhait d
accès c'est vrai mais vrai vraiment le
vraiment logique et puis vous savez je
reviens sur ce droit à la dissociation
vous avez pu observer vous êtes
observateur attentif de la vie politique
entre rouen et caen il y avait une
petite et de dissociation d'accord je ne
suis pas leur antre à puce sont plus un
autre mini
mini
pourquoi ce qui est possible entre rouen
et caen serait impossible entre besançon
et dijon et puis avant tout outre le
fait qu'on soit ministre ou pas ce qui
réunit les élus ce qui doit les réunir
c'est le sens de l'intérêt général et
c'est la république et je pense que le
gouvernement c'est là dessus qu'il va
s'appuyer pour réfléchir et pour
désigner les les préfectures préfigurer
en arrive au terme à peu près de cette
émission il nous reste un peu moins de
deux minutes faudrait que chacun vous
nous rappeler un petit peu ce que vous
êtes prêts à accepter ce que vous n'êtes
pas prêts à accepter jean le fousseret
ce que je suis prêt à accepter c'est
toutes les mesures qui feront que nous
construirons une région qui sera plus
forte uno population bourguignonne et
dijonnaise pourront et bisontine est pro
comtoise pouvons donc gagne à avoir un
plus ce que je n'accepterais pas
c'est qu'effectivement tout soit
concentré sur une seule ville je
n'accepterai pas que tout se concentrer
sur dijon et je pense que le dijonnais
sur son faux nom un partage équitable
entre nos deux capitales qui permettent
d efficace de faire des économies mais
quelque chose soit répartie alain millot
même question qu'est-ce que bien
évidemment ce que je n'accepterai pas
c'est que tout soit concentré sur une
seule ville et par delà même je peux
même dire je continuerai à militer à
travailler
quelle que soit la capitale
a travaillé pour qu'il y à une
répartition équilibrée partager comme on
a pu le le développer pendant plus de
cette émission merci alamillo merci jean
louis fousseret des zones où nous
rejoindre à dole pour cette émission
merci aude
samedi prochain rendez vous à 11h30 pour
la voie est libre chaque région prendra
son indépendance nous nous retrouverons
en revanche à nouveau ensemble pour une
émission spéciale sur la fusion des
régions ce sera le 16 mai bon week-end
au revoir merci
on
et